for those who were assuming that Lauren
bobert's re-election was a foregone
conclusion it may not be
it may not be we have some new polling
that shows it's not as bad as maybe it
seems axios reporting Lauren bobert's
re-election in Jeopardy according to a
new poll
uh by the numbers
bobert received support from 47 percent
of likely voters Democrat Adam Frisch
landed at 45. this makes the race a
statistical tie within the 4.4 plus or
minus percentage Point margin of error
seven percent of Voters are undecided
this is a survey from September 29 to
October 2nd taken by Keating research it
is a democratic firm but it is also one
of the most historically accurate
pollsters in Colorado this is a
five-point swing towards Frisch in July
it was bobert 4942
and this is a five point swing the a big
takeaway is that with bobert under 50 it
means she is vulnerable to losing the
race Frisch still has a lot of work to
do
but it is something now it's important
to understand as the axios article
points out the Third District in
Colorado overwhelmingly favors
Republicans and it is not actually
considered competitive by national
experts typically typically this is a
situation where the undecideds swing
towards the Republican in that District
538 has one of these forecasts it
currently has it at a
98 chance of bobert being re-elected and
only a two percent chance of Adam Frisch
winning not a lot of polling in this one
it is worth voting if you live in the
Third District of Colorado I know we
have viewers in that area because you've
emailed me about this race vote do not
concede it costs you nothing to also
fill out the ballot
for member of Congress and if bobert
could be defeated it would be a major
victory for Democrats we will see we
will follow the race